In today's video,
we're going to see what happens
if we extract the ink
from 1,000 glitter gel pens.
[Music]
Guys, we've done
a couple of videos
where we took the ink
out of 1,000 ballpoint pens,
and played around that ink
to really get a look at it
in a very large quantity.
On one of those videos,
we had a comment asking,
what about gel pen ink?
I thought that was
a really interesting idea
because gel pen ink
is not going to be
the same as your typical
black ballpoint pen ink.
So we got our hands
on 1,000 glitter gel pens,
and we're going to take the ink
out of all of them.
The idea here is simple.
We're going to take the ink
out of 1,000 glitter gel pens,
and really examine it.
What's it look like, feel like,
what happens when we
heat it up, freeze it,
or depressurize it.
So check this out.
This box comes with
180 different colors of pens.
Not only does it come
with 180 colors of pens,
it comes with a refill for each
of those 180 colors of pens.
So that's 360
gel ink cartridges,
and we got three of those boxes.
That's going to take us
to over 1,000 of them.
We're going to drain
all of them.
We're going to separate them
out a little bit by color.
Then we're gonna
try mixing together.
Just really take a look
at what this stuff looks like.
It should be a lot of fun.
Rather than just mix all
of the ink together at first,
I do want to kind
of separate it out,
so we can see some
of the cool colors in it.
However, we do have
180 different colors.
So what I'm going to do
is sort of separated them out
by their general color.
So I'm going to go red, orange,
yellow, green, blue, purple,
then we have pink,
and then I'm going to have
sort of a neutrals one.
That's going to be our whites,
our grays, our browns,
and our blacks.
And that one might look
a little muddy,
but they don't go too well
with any of the other colors.
Now, I did some experimenting
with the best ways to get
the ink out of the pen tubes.
One of the first things
I tried was actually just
blowing through to see if I
can get the ink out like that,
and it does work,
but it leaves
behind enough residue
that I don't think
it's the best way.
Same as last time,
I found that using one
of these little metal rods
as a plunger gets more ink out
than blowing into it does.
[Music]
1,000 pens.
Actually, a little
bit over 1,000 pens
because each box
had 360 pens in it.
We had three of those boxes,
that's 1,080.
I might have misplaced
one or two pens.
But approximately,
one thousand eighty pens.
That's a lot.
This is the ink you get
out of one pens worth.
I've got one blue pens worth,
and one pink pens
worth right here.
Lovely colors.
[Music]
That is a lot
of colored ink right there.
Holy cow.
Her neutrals is really
just sort of like IDK.
I didn't know what
that was at the time.
With the little tubes,
it's often really hard
to tell what color it is.
So I've definitely got some
in here that should have
maybe been in the yellow,
or the orange,
or even the purple.
But yeah, you just
get a little tube,
and you're like,
uh, is that brown,
or is that yellow?
Tan and yellow
look fairly similar,
like a burgundy is just going
to look black a lot of the time.
I'm not sure how I ended up with
a light purple one in there,
but I did.
But at any rate,
that's are assorted mixes.
Then we've got all
these other colors.
Red, orange, yellow,
green, blue, purple,
and a pink one
because there were a lot
of pink pens in that batch.
These look amazing.
All right, I've got
here are couple
of neutral miscellaneous colors.
I'm going to start
by stirring this all up
into seeing what color I get.
I'm gonna use my finger.
[Music]
There you go.
Sort of a slightly
purplish gunmetal kind of color.
That looks pretty cool.
I thought it was going to end
up being something really ugly.
And while I'm not saying
I want everything I own
to be painted this color,
it is kind of neat.
It's a little bit slippery.
This is definitely
way way thinner
than the other pen ink as well.
The other hand ink was
like almost gelatinous.
It had about the consistency
of corn syrup.
This is way thinner than that.
It flows a lot more.
[Music]
The other ballpoint pen ink
bubbled really nicely.
In fact, that was one
of my favorite things we did was
just blowing bubbles into it,
and watching them
grow out and burst,
and this, like I said,
is a thinner liquid,
so I kind of doubt
it's gonna bubble quite as much.
But we're going to find out.
[Music]
Definitely not getting
the same type of bubbles.
These are much smaller,
and they don't hang
around as long.
[Music]
All right, so I was doing
that just to see...
Blowing those bubbles,
and having it pop
seems to make some
of the metallic glitter sort
of raised up out of the liquid.
So now, we got
like a ring around
where I was blowing
the bubbles of just
what looks like the glitter,
or aluminum dust,
or whatever it is they put
in these pens to really get them
to shine the way they do.
[Music]
There we go.
So we've actually put one
of our cameras, the RX100,
inside on top of the glass,
looking straight down
at the ink.
The bubble seem to be pretty
small and pop pretty easily.
But once this gets down
to really low pressure,
it definitely does foam up
a lotm and it was coming
very very close to hitting
the lens of our camera,
which we don't want.
So I'm turning the pump
on and off to try and get
the air pulled out of the ink,
but not have it hit
the lens of our camera.
[Music]
I may be pushing it
a little too far.
That's sort of
our homogeneous green color.
It's what happens
when all of the different shades
of green get mixed together.
Moving on in
the natural progression
of our experimentation,
we've now got liquid nitrogen.
We're going to try dripping
some of our ink down
into liquid nitrogen.
[Music]
Formed quite nicely
into a little sphere.
I like that.
[Music]
It's bubbling a lot.
Got some cool color and swirls.
But then, we've also got
these clear spots that,
I don't know,
maybe the gel in the pigment
separate from each other
in the extreme cold.
I think now it's time
to see what happens
if we take this ink,
and heat it up.
That looks cool.
First, might just gonna take
a little bit of it,
see if it seems to be flammable.
[Music]
Doesn't really keep burning,
so it's possible that
if we get all of it really hot,
it will light on fire,
but for the most part,
just a little bit of flame
isn't doing too much.
So, let's see what happens if we
just put this on the stove.
One of the things I
definitely think will happen,
a lot of these viscous liquids
that we've tried to heating up,
they get a lot runnier,
and I'm curious to see
if that'll happen with this ink as well.
[Music]
Definitely getting thinner
as it heats up.
It's now up to almost
160 degrees Fahrenheit.
I see some of the silvery
bits, the glitter,
like joining up in some spots.
See some tiny little bits,
where it almost looks like
the metal has pooled together.
The temperature of the bottom,
where it's actually
in contact with the pan,
may easily be higher.
[Music]
Thought that would have
a much stronger smell,
but it's really
quite mild still.
So right here from this angle,
you can really see what
I was talking about.
The pigmentation and
the metallic dust
that's inside these glitter
gel pens are separating part,
and here, you can really see
all the reflections coming
off of the metallic portions.
This yellow has just
like the tiniest bit
of greenish brown to it,
and really not a very
pleasant color in my opinion.
We've also definitely evaporated
some liquid out of the ink,
because now as
it's cooling down,
it's much thicker.
That's almost got
into a paste consistency.
[Music]
Well, it might seem
a little bit destructive.
But I'm just too darn curious.
I got to see what happens
if I mix all
of the colors together.
Of course, we don't have
quite the same ratio
because our yellow
did get burned too much
in the stove to stir in.
We may have lost
little bits of the pink
when we were freezing it.
Some of the green might not have
scraped out of containers,
so it won't be 100%
perfect representation.
But I think it's gonne be close.
[Music]
Remarkably, similar to the color
we got with just blending
the neutrals together.
Here we have it,
the average color
of 1,000 pens,
which is really the same
as an average color
of 180 different colors
all mixed together.
It's just a lot more of it.
Vicky, thank you
for your suggestion.
Guys, if you've got
any cool ideas for us to try,
let us know down
in the comments.
Guys, you know that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video,
you should go check that out.
The other box is going
to show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and you see this bomb
here in the middle?
You hit that, you'll be
subscribe to the channel.
That way, you never
miss a cool video.
Don't forget to ring the bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.